DAVID GLAZER: Hello,
everyone, and welcome
to med school-- or
not quite, but we're
going to be talking
today about how
the world of the cloud
and the world of bits
is being put to use in the world
of genomics of life science
in the world of medicine.
And we have a handful
of speakers here
who are going to walk
you through a set of case
studies, a set of
examples, showing what
is it like, what does it mean,
what are the possibilities when
we take this world of the
cloud that you've been hearing
about for the last
two days and use it
in the world of life science,
the world of genomics,
the world of working with
human data, medical data,
biological data.
And I am going to start with one
slide of biology 101, genomics
101, just to kind of orient you
to some of the different topics
and applications that
you're going to be hearing.
So for those of you who
have background in this,
turn off your brain for
the next 60 seconds.
For the rest of you,
here's a very quick intro.
Pay attention,
because it's fast.
So the rough sequence
of how genomics works
is you take tissue from a human,
you run it through a machine,
a sequencing machine-- those
machines cost about $1 million
apiece-- and they spit out
this 100-gigabyte file,
which is all the raw
data from any one of us.
You then take that
data, and now we're
in the world of computing.
Now we're in the world
that we all live in.
And you take that data
and you process it
through what's called secondary
analysis down to a smaller,
more informative set of summary
information about who am I,
how am I different
from you, how are you
different from you, like that.
And then finally, you
get to the so-what stage.
And the so-what
stage is now that we
know what it is that
makes me "me" genomically,
why does that matter?
How can we put that to use?
How can we use that medically
to understand, to treat,
to reach conclusions and
insights and do interventions?
So that, in a very,
very quick pass,
is what the world of working
with genomic data looks like.
You're going to hear
some examples of people
who do primary
analysis, and therefore
have a big need for
doing secondary analysis,
and how the cloud is
helping them do it better.
You're going to hear
examples from people
who are at the far end,
in the health care side,
and how they use all of this
genomic data to get there.
And some examples
across the way.
All right, so that
was the biology 101.
Context for why this is the
right time for the cloud
and for biology and genomics
to be working together-- this
is the slide the National
Institute of Health
has been maintaining for
the last couple of decades,
and it shows a plummeting cost
of producing one human genome.
It's a slide any of you in the
field have seen repeatedly.
The takeaway here
is it's going down.
Well, what generally
happens when prices go down
is volume goes up.
And that is indeed
what's been happening.
There was an article
that came out last summer
with a catchy title.
They said that the
word "astronomical"
is an all-purpose adjective
to mean a lot of stuff.
It's kind of passe.
Astronomical isn't
the big anymore.
The word for "big"
should be "genomical,"
because they did some analysis
and they did some projections
and said, that's a log scale.
So if you look
over on the right,
you're seeing it growing from
peta-basepairs to exa- to zeta.
These are numbers that are
pretty big, and getting bigger.
The other thing I want to
point out on this chart
is if you look right
about in the middle,
there's that dot
labeled 1,000 genomes,
and around 2011 or '12.
That was a very famous big
study that was very impressive.
The world was excited to see
that, hey, we've analyzed
1,000 genomes in one place.
And people learned
a lot from that.
And 1,000 already today sounds
like a very small number.
So the feeling of
working with this data
is changing qualitatively.
That's what happens
on log scales.
So with dropping costs, with
accelerating amounts of data--
with accelerating amounts of
data that mean accelerating
not just more data but more
insights, because it's things
you can't learn from just
looking at 100 or 1,000 people.
You can only learn them when
you look at tens of thousands
and hundreds of thousands.
In that world, fortunately
the world of cloud computing
has been building the
tools to solve the problem
at the same time as the
world of life science
has been building the tools
to create the problem.
And you're going to hear
today some examples of how
this works together.
One example of a
project that's ongoing
that actually three
of the speakers
here are involved with with
us is the National Cancer
Institute has
spent, when does it
say, last five or
six years-- no,
a decade actually, last
decade-- assembling
a very interesting database
of cancer genomic data.
And they have lots of different
samples of cancer, of tumor
cells and normal cells.
And they've analyzed it,
and they have all this data.
And it's basically been
sitting on an FTP site
with a terabyte of data, which
is not the friendliest way
to analyze this
really valuable asset.
And they know this.
And they created a project to
say, let's put this out and see
if anyone can take our data
and put it in the cloud
and make it useful in the cloud.
They awarded three
grants to do that.
The three grants went to
three of the institutions who
are going to be speaking here.
And you'll hear a little
bit about what they are
doing with this information.
But this is an example of one
of the first projects that's
taking valuable data at scale,
putting it in the cloud,
and making it useful
for researchers.
There's a few.
There's going to be many more.
And you're going to hear a few
speakers talking about this.
This is the context for that.
Why do this in the cloud, right?
Why?
It's just software.
We're just analyzing stuff.
Well, the reason is
because data is data,
and a lot of the
tools that you've
been hearing about for
the last couple of days
turn out to be very
valuable and very
relevant to solving the problems
of genomics data in the cloud.
So you're going to
see examples of people
who are standing on
the shoulders of all
the tools, both general
purpose infrastructure
and dedicated
infrastructure for genomics,
and building solutions on top.
Many of them are
working with the tools
that Google builds that
are dedicated for genomics.
Many of them are using general
purpose compute platform tools.
In the world of Google
Genomics, the rough data flow--
take the data off
that sequencer,
load it into the cloud, import
it into Google Genomics,
and export it, with
the goal of making
it available to lots
of different audiences
to do their analysis,
do their work.
The four speakers
you're going to hear
are from these institutions,
from the Broad Institute, ISB,
Seven Bridges, and Stanford.
And the speakers in
particular-- you're
going to be hearing from
Kris Cibulskis at the Broad,
who's going to talk
about-- they are, I'll say,
one of the largest-- I'll
let Kris decide if he wants
to say "the largest" or not.
But they are one of the
largest genomic data factories
in the world that actually
does that primary analysis.
Therefore, they have a large
factory data analysis need.
And you'll hear him
talking about that.
Ilya Shmulevich
from ISB, Institute
for Systems Biology
in Seattle, is
going to talk about
the work they're
doing, moving downstream to
actually explore that cancer
cloud data in the cloud.
Igor Bogicevic
from Seven Bridges
is going to talk
about an application
that they have built that does
genomic analysis in the cloud.
They've had that application
running on Amazon for awhile,
and they've recently made
it available on Google Cloud
Platform.
He's going to talk to you about
his experience doing that.
And then intentionally,
we're wrapping up
with Jason Mercker
from Stanford,
who's actually the
reason all of us
are doing all the rest of this.
He works at making
people healthier.
And he's going to
talk about how we
can take all of this
other work, and what
does the tip of the
spear look like when
we try to put it into practice.
So with that, I'm going
to hand it off to Kris
to talk about the factory.
[APPLAUSE]
KRIS CIBULSKIS: All right, hi.
Hi, so I'm Kris Cibulskis.
I'm from the Broad Institute.
I'm here to talk about our first
year in the cloud of Google
Cloud Platform.
So briefly, you may not have
heard of the Broad Institute.
So let me tell you just a
little bit about who we are.
We're a nonprofit
research institute.
We were founded
with a $100 million
gift from Eli and Edythe Broad
back in 2003 as an experiment,
really, in a different way
to try to transform medicine.
We're currently powered
by about 2,400 "Broadies."
Our stated approach
to do this is
to enable researchers to act
nimbly, to work boldly, share
openly, and reach globally.
And as David mentioned,
since our leading
role in the sequencing of
the first human genome,
we've been a world leader in
the generation and analysis
of genomic data.
And in this case, I
think we are the largest
producer of genomic data,
the largest single producer.
We produce upwards of 10% of
the world's genomic data output.
But with that comes
some challenges.
So we struggle with
compute and storage.
We have 13,000 cores
on prem, but analyzing
a single one of these
human genome samples
can take eight to 10 days.
And doing an exercise where
you look across thousands
or tens of thousands of
samples to look at variation
can take upwards of 90 days.
We've got 10 petabytes
of genomic data in-house.
We're adding half
a petabyte a month.
And we asked ourselves,
can we leverage the cloud
to help address these problems?
So let's talk about our
genomic data factory.
Just for a sense of
scale, as David mentioned,
one human genome currently
requires about 100 gigabytes
of storage and takes
roughly 70 core-days
to complete analysis,
QC, and detect variation.
Our sequencer fleet can produce
140 genomes a day currently.
That's 14 terabytes
of storage every day,
and 10,000 core-days
of compute every day,
just to keep up
with the pipeline.
Oh, and we can scale that by
20% in just to three weeks.
This happened back
in December, and it
could happen again at any time.
So it's really this increase
in sequencing capability
that drives our compute
and storage needs.
So how do we leverage
the elasticity, cost,
and reliability of the
Google Cloud Platform
for our genomic data factory?
And this isn't a
one-time experiment.
It's something that
has to run 24 by 7.
We can't rewrite all of the
tools to be cloud-native.
They're not under our
control, not all of them.
And parallel implementations
is undesirable.
And finally, we'd like our
computational biologists,
our scientists--
not the software
engineers-- to be able to read
and write these pipelines.
The pipelines evolve
quickly, and we want
them to be able to keep pace.
So to enable this
transition to the cloud,
we developed an open
source software stack along
with Google Genomics, starting
with a workflow description
language called WDL, which
is an external DSL used
by the computational
biologists in order
to express their
analytical pipelines.
This is handed off to an
execution service called
Cromwell-- and both
these are open source,
and the GitHub
URLs are up there.
This is an execution service
for WDL with multiple pluggable
backends for executing against
local docker-based backends,
grid engine, and finally also,
using the Google Genomics API,
Pipeline's API,
which we co-developed
with Google Genomics.
And you could think of
this as a scalable doctor
as a service with
data scheduling.
So with this, we began to port
our data factory to the cloud.
And here's the
results of that port.
It's highly scalable.
We can currently run
100 genomes a day.
We actually just finished
a run even bigger
than that just this morning.
We have dramatic improvement in
our turnaround time per genome.
We've gone from the
eight to 10 days
I mentioned before for a
sample down to under 24 hours.
And we've got a
huge cost savings.
From the very first run we
did six months ago on GCP,
we've reduced cost by over 80%.
This is by taking advantage
of good technologies,
by splitting apart our tasks
into machines that are just
the right size and only
paying for the CPUs and memory
that each task is using.
Using preemptible VMs
is another huge win.
Going down to cheaper disks when
the particular steps were not
I/O dependent.
And finally, using
smarter zone selections
that were not preempted
as often as we
would be with a naive selection.
And also, as part of our
mission to reach globally,
this exact same
pipeline is being
delivered with Google Genomics
to the rest of the world.
This is the
pipeline-as-a-service.
It's available with a simple
API call at the URL listed here,
and it's available now.
So now that we've got
our genomic data factory
in the cloud, we wanted to
turn back to our problems
with genomic data storage.
As I mentioned before, we're
running out of storage on prem.
We've got 10
petabytes of storage,
and we're growing half
a petabyte a month.
A lot of this data is
infrequently accessed,
and we needed a
scalable archive.
And in this case, we looked
to a technology called Avere.
And Avere sits between
the Google Cloud Storage
over our internet
[INAUDIBLE] 10 gig connection
and presents an NFS mount point
to the rest of our cluster.
So we can move data
onto a mount point.
It's transparently compressed,
encrypted, and transmitted
to Google Cloud.
And we've transferred over
two petabytes this way
this month, offloading
the pressure
for our on-prem storage.
Now, with elastic storage, we
also would like cheap storage.
10 petabytes is a
lot of data to store.
And genomic data has some
interesting properties.
Very small subsets of that
100-gigabyte band file
are accessed frequently,
hundreds or thousands of times.
But it's on the order of
megabytes or kilobytes.
And the full data set is
accessed maybe once or twice
per year.
And in this case,
GCS Nearline appears
to be a near-perfect storage
temperature for this problem.
It's cheaper, about
$0.01 per gig per month,
as opposed to $0.026
cents for online.
There is a data retrieval
cost, but again, we're
not retrieving all
our data that often.
And we've got high
I/O throughput,
because your I/O
throughput is basically
enabled by the amount of total
data that you're storing.
And so with 10 petabytes
or more being stored,
we get high throughput.
And we can save over
$1.5 million a year
currently just with
these access patterns.
OK, so we've got our
factory in the cloud
and we've got our storage
problem under control.
Now we want to enable
this downstream analysis
that David talked about.
Taking a brief step back
about how large-scale genomics
research is accomplished,
the traditional way
is to bring the data
to the researchers.
So the TCGA project that
David mentioned before, we
generated a petabyte of data.
It was put into a
large national archive.
And step one if you
want to use this data
is download a petabyte of data
to your local institute, right?
This is terrible.
Data sharing is the same
as data copying now.
This requires big
infrastructure.
You've got to have
enough compute, storage,
and network connectivity.
It shuts out a ton of
people with great ideas,
because they simply don't have
that kind of infrastructure.
Of course, it's fixed.
It's not elastic.
And also, the security
implementations
at each one of these
different sites
that download this
protected data
is different and inconsistent.
They may be good,
some might be bad,
but they're certainly
not consistent.
So the cloud way,
right, would be
to bring the
researchers to the data.
We've got all the
data in the cloud.
We've got elastic
compute around it.
Data sharing is
truly data sharing.
We've got, as I mentioned,
elastic compute.
And finally, we've got
a centralized security
implementation,
so we can be sure
that it's a high quality
implementation and consistent.
So with these challenges in mind
and taking part in the National
Cancer Institute's
Cloud Pilot Project,
we developed a system
called FireCloud.
And what is FireCloud?
It's an open-source
platform with APIs
and a web portal for
securely managing, sharing,
and analyzing genomics
data in the cloud.
And it's also the way that
our genomics data factory
is going to deliver
all of our data
that we produce to
the researchers.
How did we build this?
We built it on top of
core Google Cloud Platform
technologies-- for rapid
development for one thing,
but also we wanted security
and reliability and scalability
that GCP brings.
You can see in this image
here, the blue boxes
are things that we've
custom developed.
In the center here is the
workflow description language
and Cromwell execution service
that powers our own genomics
data factory.
But it sits on top of the
Google Genomics pipeline API
compute engine
Google Cloud Storage.
And we also use Google
Identities for access control
to all of our data.
So when users log into the
system and access their data,
they can also go to GCP
directly and see their same data
in their own buckets
and enhance and extend
the system in that way.
You're not locked
in to the platform.
The data is yours.
The system is in
alpha right now,
but we're launching in early
April at FireCloud.org.
So I could've
stopped here, but I
asked if I could talk a
little bit about, well,
what could have gone better?
Not everything was 100% perfect.
The first thing was that
the security controls
as we started our project
were fairly coarse-grained,
although the talk right
before this was about the IAM
features that Google
is now rolling out.
And these are really
exciting to us,
and we're going to keep
a close eye on them.
The second problem
that we found was
with GCS buckets, if a data
owner gives read access
to other people,
they're responsible for
any egress charges incurred.
So we'd like you to keep
the data in the cloud,
but we can't prevent you from
taking it out of the cloud.
And this encourages the
anti-pattern of data
copying, rather than
sharing in place.
So finally, what's
next for us in 2016?
We're going to complete
a full transition to GCP
for our genomics data factory.
We're going to publicly
launch FireCloud
in the next few weeks.
We're going to try to
continue to reduce storage
costs by using GCS Nearline
and other advanced data
compression.
And we're going to enhance our
analytic methods-- the GATK
in particular, that's part
of this primary analysis
pipeline-- to take
advantage of more
cloud-friendly
technologies, such as spark,
data proc, and BigQuery.
And we need help.
So if you're interested,
please come seek us out.
All right, thanks
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'll turn it
over to Ilya now.
ILYA SHMULEVICH:
Hello, everyone.
My name is Ilya Shmulevich.
I am from the Institute
for Systems Biology
in Seattle, Washington.
And I would like to tell you
about our effort, the ISB
Cancer Genomics Cloud.
First, I would like to
acknowledge our team
at the ISB, with
our project lead
Sheila Reynolds and our
outstanding partners in Google
Genomics, particular Jonathan
Bingham and his team,
as well as CSRA and
David Pot and his team.
We have been part of the
Cancer Genome Atlas Project
for about six years.
David has already
introduced this project.
It has generated very large
amounts of comprehensive cancer
genomic data, unprecedented
in its size and scope.
And as part of the cancer
genome atlas as a data analysis
center, we have been
building data integration
and analytical tools, as well
as interactive visualization
and exploration
tools, to put back
into the hands of the
cancer research community.
The great challenge
has been that we
have had to precompute a lot of
that analysis-- so for example,
run correlations among the
different types of data
collected in the project and
then offer the results back
to the researchers.
Of course, that is problematic
because every researcher has
a different question
in mind, and they
want to ask different types
of questions of the data.
So the challenge is
really to, as Kris just
said, bring the
compute to the data,
bring the researcher
to the data.
And this is indeed what we have
embarked on with the ISB-CGC,
and that is to make the TCGA
data available, together
with the tools and
the compute power,
to a broad range of users
through various access modes.
And this includes interactive
web applications; scripting
languages, such as R
and Python and SQL;
as well as direct
programmatic access.
So these different
modes of access
generally correspond
to these three persona
that we have shown here.
The PI biologist, the
computational research
scientist, and the
algorithm developer.
So the PI slash biologist
may want to access these data
and explore them
in various ways,
look at correlations and
statistical associations,
ask different types of
questions of the data
in an interactive way,
but without having to do
any programming or scripting.
And the computational
research scientist
may want to combine different
types of analyses that are not
available through a web
application-- may want to bring
an additional datasets,
their own data sets,
in order to compare
them with the TCGA data.
And the algorithm developer
may wish to actually develop
a new algorithm that performs
some fundamental analysis
on the data, such as identifying
the mutations in the cancer
genomes.
And obviously, all of
these different users
would like to access
the same data,
but in very different ways.
And our platform is built
on a lot of powerful Google
technologies, such as
cloud storage for storing
the files the object store
for all of the TCGA data;
BigQuery, for storing all
of the heterogeneous data
and accessing it through a very
powerful analytical engine that
allows you to aggregate
results from enormous datasets
literally in seconds; and
through the Google Genomics
API, which is a platform
that is optimized
for storing sequence reads
that come off the sequencer.
And it can hand handle
petabytes of data.
So we have already placed all
of the TCGA data, approximately
one petabyte of it,
onto Google Cloud
Platform that is
stored on Google Cloud
Storage and BigQuery.
And most of these data
are sequencing data,
if you count in terms of size.
So 99.8% of the data
are sequence data, DNA
and some RNA sequence data.
However, if you look
at the number of files
and the heterogeneity and
the complexity of the data,
about 0.2% of the
data in terms of size
actually comprise about
340,000 different files
that contain clinical data
and protein expression data,
and data on different
parts of the genome that
are amplified or deleted,
and a lot of other types
of measurement data.
So this is really a great
challenge for researchers.
It's not just the
size of the data,
but it's really the complexity.
How do we put it all
together and analyze it
in an integrative fashion?
So we have loaded all of
these datasets into BigQuery.
So every type of data is
available in its own BigQuery
table that then
allows us to integrate
them to query these
different BigQuery tables
and integrate the
results to perform more
comprehensive analysis than is
possible with individual data
types alone.
So let's go through these
three access modes quickly.
So the PI slash
biologist would like
to access different
types of cancer data sets
and look at various
associations in the data.
So you could, for
instance, construct
a cohort that is comprised
of multiple different cancer
types.
There are 33 different cancer
types available in TCGA.
So suppose you wanted
to study the cancers
of the digestive tract by
combining esophageal, stomach
cancer, and colon cancer
together in one dataset,
and then analyzing that dataset
and perhaps comparing it
with another one.
Or you could construct
a cohort that is based
on some molecular feature.
For example, you could look
at all 33 counts or types
and select only
the ones that have
a mutation in a particular
gene of interest.
OK.
And then we have
various visualizations
that are wired to
these BigQuery tables
that interactively allow the
user to explore the data.
For example, we have been
working with the Integrated
Genome Viewer Team
from UCSD, and have
deployed the IGB viewer that
can fetch the data directly
from the Google Genomics API.
So it can get the reads and
display them graphically
in an interactive fashion.
So if you're looking for that
mutation in the cancer genome,
you can then see the
evidence for that mutation
in those reads.
We also have scatter
plots that can
get the data from
different BigQuery tables
and display them interactively
in a scatter plot like this,
where you can color different
samples by the cancer types.
Or, in the far right,
you see a visualization
of mutation frequencies.
We're looking at a
particular protein
and across many different
types of cancer,
and we can see the places
on the protein that
harbor these mutations.
You can already
visually see that there
are certain hotspots where
these mutations occur
more frequently than in
other places in the genome.
If you're a
computational scientist,
you probably want
to write scripts.
You want to analyze the data
with R or with Python or SQL.
So we have created a number
of examples and templates
to make it easier for
you to get started.
For each of these data types
that is available in BigQuery,
we have templates written
in R and in Python
that show you how you
can fetch the data
and then do something
simple with them.
If you like to use
packages, such as
the popular Bioconductor
suite of open-source software
for bioinformatics,
you could do that.
Or if you'd like to query the
Google Genomics API directly
from your R client, you
could do that as well.
So here is one quick
example in Python,
actually running on
Google Cloud Datalab, that
fetches so-called copy number
variation data from BigQuery.
This data specifies
which parts of the genome
have more copies
and less copies.
You may remember from
your high school biology
that we all have two copies
of every part of our genome,
one from our mom and
one from our dad.
But in cancer cells, very
often there are more copies.
You could have three or
four or five or more copies.
And also, you may
have less copies.
You might have only one copy of
your gene, or even zero copies
when the gene is
completely deleted.
So we can look at these
data across 11,000 tumors,
look at millions of these
segments of the genome
to see whether they are
amplified or deleted,
and draw a histogram like
this in roughly two seconds,
just by fetching all of this
information from BigQuery
and displaying it
as a histogram.
This is really
transformational for research,
because it opens
up possibilities
of analyzing very large
data sets quickly, getting
the answers, and using
those answers to ask
the next question.
Because research is really
an iterative process.
If you're an
algorithm developer,
you own your own Google project.
You get automatic access
to Google's Cloud Storage,
BigQuery, the Google
Genomics API, and as well
as the other Google
Compute technologies,
such as Compute Engine,
Container Engine, and Dataflow.
Of course, you can invite other
people to your collaborators,
to your Google Cloud project.
We also use the
Cloud Endpoints API,
which is backed by App Engine
so that you can do everything
from the command
line that you can
do from the web application.
For example, you
can authenticate
from the command line.
You can make requests to
get a list of your cohorts
or look at the details of your
cohort, save a new cohort,
or get a list of data files that
is associated with a cohort.
I would like to end by
acknowledging the National
Cancer Institute for
funding these projects,
and invite you to
visit the ISB CGC.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
IGOR BOGICEVIC: Hi, everybody.
I'm Igor Bogicevic
from Seven Bridges.
And first of all, before
I get into how it actually
looked like for us to move
from AWS to Google Cloud
and what were the challenges and
actual results of this process,
I would like to tell you a
little bit about what we do.
We are building the robust,
scalable, and secure platform
for actually data analysis
and biomedical analysis,
with a specific emphasis
on the genetic data.
And to do that, we
actually had to build
various aspects of the platform
that are completely detached
from the actual infrastructure.
And we are also the strong
supporters of open standards
and reproducibility.
We support the common
worker language,
and we are one of the leading
members of the community push
to CWL to actually
bring competition
from your workstation
to your cluster,
and eventually to cloud.
And we designed our platform
for portability, which basically
means that our primary goal was
to build a platform in a way
that you can actually bring
the platform to the data,
and wherever this
data sit, it doesn't
mind for us whether your data is
in AWS, Google, or your phone.
And if your phone would be a
good computational resource,
there is no reason why
we wouldn't use it.
But we are not there quite yet.
So we actually rely
on the cloud platforms
as such to actually bring
the computational analysis
to the end users.
And we've found that the
Google Cloud was fantastic
infrastructure for us.
And [INAUDIBLE] how we
look under the hood.
This is a small diagram
that very generally shows
how we actually decoupled
our infrastructure
from the actual resources.
And this helped us a
great deal to actually get
to the Google Cloud.
Of course, it's not easy to
move from one infrastructure
to the other infrastructure
and actually build
the whole platform.
But given the great resources we
could find in the Google Cloud,
we found it to be
even easier for us
than we actually
anticipated originally
to support Google
Cloud Platform as well.
So why are we building all this?
So why would anyone want
to build this platform?
As you heard, we are working in
a space that's very exciting.
And there is a huge promise
that all the work we are doing
will actually give the
benefits to the end users.
And our customers are
working on genomics research
for cancer drug development
and precision medicine.
And a couple of
projects we're really
proud of that we worked on
is the Pan-Cancer Analysis
of Whole Genome.
And we helped the International
Cancer Genome Consortium
to actually finish
the whole process
and process over 500 cancer
genomes in less than two days.
We are also one of the NCI
Cancer Genomics Cloud pilots.
And we are happy to
share this stage together
with the other two pilots.
And we are only industry
trusted partner to do so.
Moreover, we also
are working together
with Genomics England
and 100k Genomes Project.
And we are actually
to them trying
to commercialize our
[INAUDIBLE] and solutions
for actually
populational genomics
through the graph genome.
And moreover, we are also
very happy to announce
two projects that
are directly related
to President Obama's
Personalized Medicine
Initiative.
First one is Cavatica, that
we're building together
with Children's Hospital
of Philadelphia.
It's actually trying to
address children cancer.
And we also have recently signed
a credo together with Lockheed
Martin, and we are
working together
with Veterans Affairs on
Million Veteran Project data.
And we're trying to help
them analyze currently
the biggest cohort
of [INAUDIBLE]
typical and atypical
paired data.
So let's get to what we are
really here in our story.
So I'm going to
share a short war
story of how this whole part
of our platform will look like.
And it's actually quite
boring, which is good.
Boring in software is
usually very, very good.
So what we actually
found is that we
had relatively compatible
computational and storage
resources, which
means it was not
very hard for us to transfer
our whole platform to the Google
Cloud.
And we didn't have
any major blockers.
Actually, the major
challenges were
how could we actually
optimally use
the computational resources,
and how to actually benchmark
those resources and figure
out how to use optimally
the whole infrastructure
that Google provided for us--
and especially, how to figure
out the efficient transfer
to and from Google Storage.
Because as you
heard, we are working
with very, very large data
sets, and speed of transfer
really matters.
And what we really liked
is that we actually could
design custom machine types.
And that means that
you can actually
design the machine type that
fits the computation and tools
you're running the best.
You can actually choose how
many CPU power do you need,
how many memory you need.
And actually, you
can also attach
the very, very
flexible and fast SSD
storage, which really mattered.
And one thing, we also found
that it was cheaper on average
and much simpler to manage
computational resources
for various compliances compared
to AWS, where we had to deal
with dedicated tendency.
Here, everything that we used
was pretty much HIPAA-compliant
and could be designed for
other compliances, as well.
So I would like to share the
results of our benchmarks.
You can see relatively
similar instance types here.
What we found very exciting,
besides just the much faster
average instance book, is that
the total cost is 40% lower.
And that's even before using
preemptable virtual machines,
which significantly
reduce costs even further.
And just to give an
overview of the benchmark,
we used so-called Seven
Bridges whole genome
sequencing pipeline.
And we used Illumina test read
files and standard references.
And we already
mentioned CWL pipeline,
which you can actually
easily transfer it
from CGC Seven Bridges platform
to Amazon Seven Bridges
platform to Google
Seven Bridges platform.
And one thing that actually
makes this benchmark
not so super exact is that
the instance types are not
super similar.
They're as similar as possible,
but not exactly the same.
However, this was the machine
that you've seen here mentioned
is actually the machine
type that was pretty much
benchmarked as the fastest
instance type on Amazon
platform that we could find.
So besides that, I could say
that this platform is alive
currently on Google
Cloud Platform.
And you can access
it through the URL.
You can create the account.
You can play with the pipeline
so you have some free credit.
You can check it out.
If you like it, you
can run [INAUDIBLE],
use it with already
existing data.
And we will encourage
you to do so.
And just to conclude, so
our conclusion basically
is why we find
this important, why
we find the significantly
lower amounts of money
that we spend on executing
pipelines is important.
Any dollar that we actually
don't spend on the compute
is actually a dollar that can
be used to generate the data,
further analyze data, and
actually get to the point
why we are actually
even building this.
And this is creating the better
treatments for the patients,
and actually further improve
on the personalized medicine
and health in general.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JASON MERKER: Hi,
good afternoon.
My name's Jason Merker.
I'm one of the two co-directors
of the Stanford Medicine
Clinical Genomics
Service, and today I'm
going to talk about
a project where
we use cloud
infrastructure to provide
better genetics-guided
care to our patients.
So our service is a joint effort
between the Stanford University
School of Medicine,
shown here, as well as
our adult and pediatric
health care systems.
We are a clinical service that's
housed within the hospitals,
and consequently we are subject
to unique regulatory, security,
legal, and other business
requirements for cloud compute
and storage.
And I'll touch on those briefly.
So we started as a pilot
in January of 2014,
where we developed the workflow
and evaluated the feasibility
by working through 100 cases.
We use genome sequencing to
evaluate the cause of disease
in patients with suspected
genetic disorders.
This involves looking at
2.85 billion positions
throughout an
individual's genome.
So we focus on four
disease areas--
childhood mystery
diseases, familial cancer,
familial heart disease,
and unusual reactions
to medications.
However, I think the best
way to describe what we do
is to walk you through a case.
This is a family
that's been seen
in our medical center
for over 10 years,
and despite very extensive
testing as well as
consultations from a
variety of physicians,
the diagnosis remained unknown.
So this falls into the general
category of pediatric mystery
diseases.
And this was two
siblings, both who had
very similar clinical findings.
So they presented early in life
with progressive cerebellar
ataxia.
This is a lack of control
during voluntary movements,
such as walking or
picking up objects.
This is associated with
atrophy or shrinkage
of the back portion of the
brain, the cerebellum, that
controls such movements.
In addition, the patients
exhibit intellectual disability
and the other findings
that I've described here.
So we performed genome
sequencing on the family
and identified two
inactive copies of SNX14.
And although this
finding was suspicious,
it was insufficient
to act on clinically
because the gene had not
been previously implicated
in human disease.
Through an essentially
random hallway chat,
we learned of another
group that had actually
observed 20 cases, all with
very similar clinical findings,
and all of these 20 individuals
had two inactive copies,
again of the SNX14 gene.
So both copies were inactivated.
So based on this, we had
sufficient information
to make a diagnosis.
And these findings were
eventually published.
But if we were to wait
for the publication,
for the information to be
indexed and us to reanalyze
the case, it may have taken
an additional two years
to get to this point.
So it really emphasizes
the importance
of data-sharing efforts,
such as those that
have been described here today.
So what does this
mean for the family?
So it ends a 10-year
diagnostic odyssey.
It provides the
family information
about the disease course
and associated management
approaches based on now a
cohort of 30 individuals
across at least 15 families.
The gene is involved
in a cellular process
for which targeted therapies
are under investigation.
So there may be therapeutic
options in the future.
However, it underscores
the importance
of arriving at a
diagnosis early,
before too much damage
is already done.
So the pilot was
deemed successful
by our supporting
organizations, and we
were asked to transition from
a pilot to production phase.
The pilot worked well.
However, it was slow
and really not scalable.
We need to be able go from
one patient to many patients.
And there were
several challenges,
particularly involved in compute
and storage infrastructure,
which I'll describe today, which
we think Google Cloud provided
the answers.
So beginning in the summer
of 2015, here are the issues.
So the first is
an issue of scale.
So conservatively,
we know that we
need to examine about
3,000 patients per year
in a health care system.
At the same time, we also
believe that genetic testing
is going to be important
for the majority of patients
in our health care system.
But we don't know when.
So we needed to
find a solution that
would allow us to scale
the need, including fairly
rapid and massive scaling.
An elastic cloud provides this.
So the second issue,
as I mentioned--
we are housed within
a clinical service,
and there are three
entities involved with that.
There are complex security,
legal, regulatory,
and other business requirements
associated with this.
And after due diligence,
these entities
felt comfortable with
appropriate configuration.
Google Cloud was an
appropriate place
to put both protected
health information as well
as genomic data.
And then the last
thing we were looking
for is a team that had
additional experience
in genetics and
genomics as a value add.
Stanford has many
ongoing collaborations
with Google Genomics,
and we were confident
that they would make
our service better.
In addition, thinking about
what we do on a day-to-day basis
is essentially search.
We search the EMR for
certain clinical findings.
We search the literature and
databases for variance genes,
as well as associated
clinical findings.
This is obviously a
core function of Google,
and we think this
will help us provide
better genetics-guided
health care to our patients.
So the transition to
cloud is well underway.
We're targeting a formal
launch of the service
at the end of this year.
And then we especially
want to thank
our patients and the
health care providers,
likewise the many individuals
at Stanford Medicine,
as well as Google, that
made this possible.
Thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID GLAZER: All right.
Thank you, Jason.
A couple minutes of just
wrap-up-- what you've just seen
are several examples
of how people
are building on top of
the cloud to move forward
in the world of life science.
The general theme here--
why does this all matter?
Well, Jason ended
it with the example
of exactly why it matters.
It matters because
when one of us
is sick, when someone
we love is sick,
we want to use the best
knowledge, the best
information, bring it to
bear, the best understanding.
The way we get that
knowledge is by studying
thousands, and
hundreds of thousands,
and millions of people.
That's where you need the scale
of data that's now possible.
Wet science and dry
science have come together
to really get this
virtuous cycle working.
Two 10-second tastes
of where it's going--
remember at the beginning,
I said a few years ago there
was a very exciting
groundbreaking scale
with the 1,000 genomes project.
And that's now a small number.
These are ongoing projects
getting started now.
Genomics England has an
100,000 Genomes Project
that was mentioned earlier
that they're getting going,
with exactly this n equals many.
Let's learn.
And President Obama, when he
launched the Precision Medicine
Initiative, exactly the
same insight-- let's
build a cohort of a
million volunteers,
get information from them,
including genomic information,
take all the kinds
of tools and analyses
we've learned about today,
and use it to learn from n
equals many so that each
of us, when we need it,
have the tools and
information needed
to help us and our loved ones.
I'd like to close with
thanking Kris and Ilya and Igor
and Jason.
And thank you all for listening.
We're going to hang
around at the front
if anyone has
questions afterward.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]